this is a production of Cornell
University
so what I'm going to do today is talk
almost exclusively about on the Graduate
research they have contributed heavily
on advancing the chemistry and for my
college and natural products in my life
so I'm going to present a montage of
most relevant projects that have they
have undertaken so I'm going to start a
little bit with Jesus lipidomics and
referring in particular to lipid such as
for for lipid sphingolipids not really
bitten we now see diets and then I'm
going to spend the rest of the time
talking about the cease targeted
botanical pharmacology with emphasis on
particular diseases since that is what
really drives a plant research in in my
lab so let me start with a little bit
about self chemical biology and that's
by way of a very early project that our
undergrad undertook in my lab his name
was or is Michael Ginsberg is an MD
degree now and up so so at a time that
we initiated this project and was
financed by a hatch brand the egg
industry in the state of New York was
under heavy financial stress and that is
because regulation was changing and now
small and medium large egg producers
needed to accommodate chicken housing
requirements such as larger spaces etc
etc that was put in a lot of stress on
them and so there was a call for grant
proposals on research as to how expand
the market of eggs and possibly the
development of
added value products so this got my
interest because thinking as a chemist I
look at the egg as an a chemical factory
actually so it one looks at the
structure over there is heavily
compartmentalize the one third of the
weight of an egg is the egg yolk and the
egg yolk exactly chock-full of lipids
okay and probably you know a little bit
about the stories around cholesterol in
eggs except sarah which actually have
been debunked already there is not
thread of cholesterol intoxication from
eggs so so the egg yolk actually is
greatly composed of what we call overall
as lecithin which is a mixture of
phospholipids and you're familiar with
the structure of phospholipids a literal
backbone phosphorylated with a head
group that can be colleen ethanolamine
syrian of or inositol and Isetta lated
by various types of fatty acids so
eggless it actually has an application
in medicine and that is the
pharmaceutical industry utilizes the
lesson to formulate drugs that are going
to be actually administer rent early
that is there going to be a minister
intravenously for example right so their
drugs that actually cannot be made what
a soluble and therefore they need to be
formulated in these vesicles so Egla
sitting has the capacity to form I seals
that can then include different types of
therapeutic agents the only problem is
that well this my seals have had some
kind of compatibility with mammalian
cell membrane composition so so the idea
then was to look at the possibility
of deriving from eggs from the state of
New York that were appropriate in
composition for this application so I
felt the need to put some you no
economic data into the whole adventure
as a justification and just recently the
USDA has established that the value of a
grade a large egg is 13 cents now if you
look at signals catalogue they sell 250
milligrams of reagent grade a lesson for
$59 right so one grade a large egg
contains two grams of lesson worth 472
dollars of course I'm not including you
know production costs obviously but this
is just too exaggerated make the point
all right now in theory if you calculate
you know you can increase the value of
an egg by more than 3,000 times in a
closet in value right so in any event so
but the question is I said is this
lesson actually suitable for used by the
pharmaceutical industry well I recruited
participation of a New York State egg
producer creek farm fresh eggs Kurt
career is actually the main owner of the
company is saying family-owned business
actually Lisa it's a medium-sized egg
producer at they have they have like a
hundred fifty thousand layers so uh and
he is actually a Cornell alum so he
gladly participated providing eggs in
addition to providing eggs he provided
also proprietary diet we felt very
strongly that the less it in derive from
this eggs was going to depend on the
chemical composition of the diet so he
provided two types of chicken feeds that
they use in the farms non eb and
be and those are designations that only
they know what they mean right no is
proprietary to diet so and then the
corresponding eggs produced with the
different diets so the methodology
utilized it's actually extremely simple
one cracks the egg separates the yolk
and then the yolk is extracted with a
mixture of growth for methanol in two to
one ratio evaporated to dryness and
prepare for sampling and introduction
into a mass spectrometer so at a time in
the core facility we have a squire LC
electrospray ionization mass
spectrometer that one could actually
operate so that was the playground for
us for the next three years actually so
it's a very robust instrument we're very
limited in capacity of data processing
because it's single octupole and ion
trap but in any event it was very
suitable for the analysis of this lesson
so a lot of math you crank a lot of data
data processing and this is basically
the results that we that we receive mind
you this is the average mammalian cell
membrane lipid composition the main
component is phosphatidylcholine PC
followed by phosphatidylethanolamine and
then a little bit of
phosphatidylinositol so we characterize
the composition profile of the feeds are
in compared with a sample of commercial
resident that is utilized in by the
pharmaceutical industry as you can see
the nany be feed has little pc are large
amounts of PE and little pie however the
EB feeds have larger amounts of PC
comparable amounts of PE and
both probably fee the fee that compares
best with the green bars which or the
composition of the commercial
pharmaceutical grade lesson that
contains large amounts of pc is is the
one now this is the profile of the
lesson that come the chickens that were
fed one and the other diet and as you
can see very they very very differently
the composition of the of the diets so
the composition that is closest to the
commercial lesson it's actually the eggs
that were laid from chickens that were
fed and on eb chicken feed and it's
almost equal to the to the commercial
one same amounts in PE and very little p
I so it will look at the lesson
composition of the eggs that come from
chickens that were fed the non EV diet
is very very close to the to the
mammalian cell membrane composition so
those were the results that we received
and of course you will passed on
recommendations we felt also that you
know the diets can be optimized to
better adjust then the profile needed
for suitable news by the pharmaceutical
industry given the fact that the diet it
is very influential in this composition
that's why organic and omega 3 eggs can
be produced you just feed those
components to them to the chicken and
voila you get x ty have high content of
omega-3s
and just to illustrate that in addition
to the quantification of the
phospholipid classes we actually did a
very detail species profile for each one
of the classes and this is one example
so for each one of the phospholipids we
actually identified each one of the
particular species these numbers
represent the added number of carbons
coming from the two AC groups in the end
the actual phospholipid including it's a
level of its saturation alright so this
actually led to a very robust research
collaboration with a group of Susan
Henry that to this day it is maintained
and in this particular case we actually
looked at lipidomics and the lipid ohm
of yeast cells and through the
manipulation of different growth
conditions and the use of gene delete
mutants we have a better understanding
now how this metabolic pathways or
actually regulated so we were fortunate
that a newer machine and more capable
was acquired by the core facility we now
have a triple quadrupole machine that
can do a multiple reaction monitoring
that allows us in combination with hplc
to elucidate in one analysis more than
100 lipid species in in samples so this
is the lipid ohm of yeast depending on
the growth stage we normally work with
these populations that are in this
particular early developmental stage and
he used the whole profile of lipids
cardiolipin sterols swingle lipids the
phospholipids neutral lipids and the
lies of products this design is as an
example the most important phospholipid
in yeast is what
material inositol this is the
composition / species of the steady
state however using an hour a very anal
innovative use of the stable isotope we
can actually look at the Nobel synthesis
of all these species and therefore by
comparison with the composition of the
steady-state infer the level of or
degree of remodeling that this also
lipids actually undergo so so this is
this is what we do in combination with
all the genetics behind the least so I'm
going to move now on to really what I
want to spend the rest of the time
discussing that is this is targeted
botanical pharmacology these are the
particular diseases that we are
interested in in my lab is it looks very
ambitious but actually on a preliminary
stage they're very very accessible as I
will illustrate I will come actually I
will concentrate primarily only on
cancer and the epigenetics of cancer
Alzheimer's disease and a more recent
line research that we have which is our
menopause so a definition no botanical
pharmacology can be the accumulated
developing knowledge of the effect that
mode of action of natural products
occurred in plants in the prevention and
treatment of disease and I feel that by
studying and investigating the mode of
action of a natural product we are
better prepared to provide from a
suitable industry with lee compounds
that can actually result in a clinical
clinical therapy so i would like to
every time that i talk about a line of
research i would like to introduce you
know the students at participating in
them and as you can see progress in this
type of projects it's punctuated in
cumulative
and it has cents you know generation
some undergrads as they move on and that
knowledge and skill and methodological
capacity it's actually maintained and
new students or trained under it so some
of the early students that I had was
Douglas Ryan and more recently Chelsea
there are these two graduate students or
actually senior graduate students and
programs in pharmacology Rockefeller and
Weill Cornell and you're almost done
with their with their PhD work so to
introduce our interest in in cancer from
the epigenetic standpoint I have
summarized here you know the views of
the mechanisms of cancer now the
classical view is one in which the
genome has experienced some kind of
change introduced by mutations deletions
of genes or gene amplifications and this
is the classical view and the one that
has been more investigated and for which
there is more information however there
is an evolving alternative you and that
is that epigenetic mechanisms can
actually end the dysfunctionality can
also result in cancer so mechanisms by
with by which gene expression can take
place is by histone modification DNA
methylation and non-coding RNA so these
two histone modifications and DNA
methylation actually have been
investigating the context of cancer and
found out that actually they contribute
to the unregulated proliferation of
cancer cells and for those two there are
already two drugs that are being used
clinically to the treatment of certain
matter logic ah cancers so my interest
in particular and
in a moment how will you will see why
was actually histone modification ms
regulation of histone modification can
is actually due to the development of
cancer so just to remind you histone
modification can occur in particular by
a mechanism of oscillation and
deacetylation those changes actually are
accomplished by enzymes that we call
histone deacetylases or histone
acetyltransferases so isolated chromatin
leads to gene silencing deacetylated yes
at elation of chromatin leads to
relaxation and accessibility to the gene
expression so Miss regulation of this
mech of this mechanism actually can
result in cancer and here is illustrated
so one particular histone deacetylase
that has been identified in a couple of
cancers as is third one this is a
mammalian histone the surface so it can
desert lays histones but he can also
deacetylase proteins and illustrated
here or two proteins that actually are
yet the isolation of those two proteins
can resolve actually in cancer one
protein is p53 that if sirt1 deacetylase
deactivates and therefore it precludes
the mechanism by which a cell that has a
a leash Leah a na that is a damaged
cannot undergo apoptosis or DNA repair
or growth cell development and that
result in tumor suppression so if that
certain one the Isetta lace is actually
miss regulated it can inactivate or the
give a p53 or on the other hand you can
actually activate an oncogene like bcl6
that is actually a transcriptional
repressor that can resolve in to
Morgana's bcl-6 and the acceleration of
it has been implicated in a particular
type of lymphoma so there is a certain
one homolog actually in yeast and that
is Sir two so 32 is also a histone
deacetylase and actually can silence at
silence at the tell America gene satin
ellamarie region it's a family of
histone deacetylases surtout is the most
important but he forms complexes with a
freezer for the whole the cold sirtuins
and the isolation actually silences
chromatin so to to study he stone
deacetylation in the context of finding
natural products that can actually
prevent their action and end the
treatment of cancer we we had a
challenge so before I go on to describe
the methodology that we develop to do
that let me just say that these two
histone desilicious small molecules at a
time that we were looking into the
possibility of undertaking this type of
project had actually been identified so
and these two chemicals actually were
critical in deciding what type of
natural product we were going to target
in the possibility that we could set up
some kind of methodology to measure
these two entities this particular
molecule have been isolated from a phone
call from a fungal isolate that was in
the repository or the
Cancer Institute and skull split
amaizing and he was found out that it
was a histone deacetylase officer to
actually in yeast the other compound is
called saha for short is a synthetic
compound and in 2006 receive a proof
approval from the FDA to treat this
particular type of cell lymphoma so with
this type of chemistry in the background
and knowing a little of natural products
one could think of natural product
candidates that could be put through a
an asset to look for histone deacetylase
activity so the question is you know
where and what to look for he's done
just a lazy division activity so knowing
that so using these structures as
templates what came to mind was actually
coumarins so humans have this particular
basic skeleton this is a chrome own this
is a chrome and own so you can see right
away the similarity between the two
structures so we decided that coumarins
because they bear quite close
resemblance to spear myosin could
actually be good candidates for histone
deacetylase in division so as we know
humans are widely distributed they wrote
easy as Tracey and in soma BAC now the
other group of natural products that
we're closely resembling saha or
actually alkyl amides ok so this type of
compounds or widely distributed Lee
wrote AZ Piper AZ and some ass crazy and
as you can see there is an overlap
between the presence of coumarins and
alka mites in the route i see so
courtesy became the first target family
you know to investigate for this type of
activity so the question is how we're
going to do this so
so here we actually I saw the advice of
the Suzanne Henry group and decided that
well if we're going to use yeast to
investigate histone deacetylase activity
then we need to actually engineer a
yeast strain that will have a reporter
gene and the reporter gene that was
decided to use was a year three reporter
gene introduced in the telomeric red
region where the sirtuins histone
deacetylases and yeast actually operate
so if the chromatin is the set elated
there is no you're three expression if
it is a set elated then there will be
your three expression so we need to
translate this this theoretical concept
into into practice so okay so I'm not
going to discuss the conditions that are
required for this expression and how the
reporting is going to take place and I
rather described how we accomplish
actually this so the yeast strain that
was actually engineered was a done with
a plasmid that was actually provided by
Thomas feeds from University of North
Carolina that contained actually the
whole right arm of chromosome 5 in which
the urine three gene reported gene had
been introduced in the telomeric region
so by homologous recombination we
actually engineer a yeast strain that
contained now the reporter gene in the
appropriate place so now what what is it
that you're at three does well you're
three actually is a decarboxylase in the
uracil battle about synthetic pathway
from arte to uracil that removes the
carboxyl group from or auditing 5
phosphate and yielding uridine model
mono phosphate so now in this type of
methodologies one can actually give
where the gene is operational we can
give the cells this particular compound
by floral erotic acid so this is a
historic acid that has a fluorine in
this position and if the cell processes
it it results in the formation of this
suicide inhibitor which is 540 uracil so
depending on whether we allow for you
know you're a tree to be expressed or
not we kill or not cells right so now we
have a way to actually set a an asset to
do that so illustrated here is if the
sirtuins the Isetta late they tell the
telomeric region so the cells can
actually grow in the presence of 5 fo a
because you're a tree is actually non
expressed but if the sirtuins the Isetta
late and yer 3 is actually expressed
then the cells are not going to grow
because they're going to form this
compound which is actually toxic to them
so that can be done very easily in
liquid media but I have always had a
tendency to simplify things for
expediency and AH what I wanted to
develop was a essay on the same basis
but that actually could be used in solid
media so the concept was if we deposit a
histone deacetylase in a filter disk and
we introduce it in a petri dish and
inoculate with this particular construct
will it show cell growth in a vision so
here's the proof of concept nicotinic
acid is a histone deacetylase inhibitor
and you can see that in the presence of
it there is no cell growth and without
it sales grow so now we have a system
rather
simple but at the same time complex
because of the type of reporting that we
can actually now interrogate natural
product chemistry for his notice at
least in a vision so as I said the
rotation the first target family to
investigate for natural product
chemistry that could actually inhibit
histone deacetylation so at the time it
was almost winter and so we had to refer
to what we had in the greenhouse and we
had actually two species of citrus so we
had this particular repay see citronella
Metis kumquat and we had actually Lymon
so we prepare actually extracts of the
leaves of these two root AC and then we
put him through the assay and the result
was that well the crude chemistry of an
methanol extract of this route AC
actually the one from the Limon doesn't
inhibit the growth of the cell so that
means that there is no histone
deacetylation division while the extract
of kumquat does so so we pursue then the
chemistry of submitting Metis in this
particular case we were actually
targeting and the reason why we tested
methanol extracts is because we were
targeting via the humor in sin in citrus
so we pursue similes and so this right
away became a big challenge because we
could not reproduce this biological
activity at wheel and every time that we
prepared an extract of a kumquat and
tested we would either get a positive
result or we would not get a resolved at
all and this was very puzzling and after
reviewing data accumulated we notice
that the only extracts that were giving
a positive result we're aged
quote-unquote x
and that that aging required at least
one month of sitting on the bench if we
tried freshly prepared extracts there
was no activity along so this was
actually later confirmed when we started
now to suspect that there was a
difference between the two types of
extracts okay so we applied the
chemistry to that we compare composition
hplc composition profiles of old and age
extracts and we found that actually
there was a change in profile in which
one compound in the arm that was
prominent in the fresh extract in the
one-month-old extract actually are
decreasing concentration while another
camp compound actually or component
actually experienced the opposite okay
so he started with very low
concentrations and after one month it
was actually hi this already suggested
to those was that this changing
composition actually was key to the
biological activity we further test the
dye hypothesis using mass spectrometry
and that we found in effect there is a
compound that in the fresh extract is
very long concentration it has a
molecular weight of 377 and after one
month actually is high right so we went
after that compound we did you know by
us a guided fractionation and that
actually resulted in the elucidation of
the active principle that it is only
active after the parent compound has
actually produced it in large amounts we
don't know the mechanism by which this
change occurs whether it is chemical or
biochemical nevertheless it was
confirmed here is the comparison of the
mass spectrum of the parent compound and
this is the mass spectrum of the product
that is the active one which is the
result of the loss of these two sugar
moieties so this compound
which is a coumarin a puree no coumarin
for that matter is actually a histone
deacetylase inhibitor so other students
came along and we targeted in a
different rotations plant some toxic
long americano in this particular case
northern prickly ash curse in the area
we collected it it had been reported
that some talks real Americana contain
five-member p5 mo PA coumarin in this
particular outcome I'd five alpha
hydroxy sensual so we wanted to find out
if either one of these two type of
compounds actually work histone
deacetylases so extracts actually will
prepare tested here is the response
strong response to one partially
purified fraction that came from column
chromatography and we further pursue
this biological activity and it resulted
then in a fraction that was rich in a
family of compounds which are actually
derivatives of couse video which is a
phenylpropanoid type of compound so we
further our fractionating using silica
gel column chromatography gradient in
separation we found fractions that were
active and that by thin-layer
chromatography showed that it was only
one compound they all contain it we
combined and test it and the activities
right there so the compound that was
identified by my suspect rama tree is
actually this GU speedy old analogue
goose pedic acid that's what we call in
it and it's actually a histone
deacetylase inhibitor
so we took a different Avenue to
fractionation of Sun toxin Lemire kind
of extracts and we isolated also an
additional histone deacetylase gamma
sensual which it hasn't had it hadn't
been reported actually in some toxin
americanum and so here's the structure
is it is actually an alkaloid so you
know the choosing of the retains because
they combine this type of chemistry that
has been shown by analogy to be hit on
the settle is it paid out actually so we
have now in summary a few compounds one
fear and of coumarin and one
phenylpropanoid and actually one alkyl
amide so all this in the course of about
four years all right so let me move on
now to to a different disease and this
is Alzheimer's so Alzheimer's is
becoming a big problem not only in North
America but globally as we have an
increasing aging population that it will
experience certain incidents of
Alzheimer's disease that in combination
with the fact that current therapies in
the treatment of Alzheimer's disease or
actually are not very efficacious
clinically so this interest in
Alzheimer's actually started out in 2009
with these two students Scott Michael
both of them already were awarded their
in mt degrees and newer students like
Bernal and Rowley an event so this is
the neuropathology of Alzheimer's very
early dawn upon postmortem studies it
was actually found out that an
Alzheimer's patient brain actually has
experienced considerable shrinkage and
you know neuronal loss mainly occurs in
the cerebral cortex in the hippocampal
region where the cholinergic Network
resides
and the cholinergic network actually is
responsible for memory and cognition so
as you can see affecting these parts of
the brain results in loss of those two
functions so histological preparations
had also shown that associated with is
neuronal loss or the formation of
plaques that now we call him happy
knowing beta amyloid plaques and also
accumulation of protein tau protein fear
ills inside of the cells all right all
that causes Alzheimer's disease so based
on these results and biochemical studies
of brains of Alzheimer's individuals it
was noted actually that levels of
acetylcholine the neurotransmitter in
these areas of the brain was actually
very low so the first hypothesis or
model proposed for the disease was one
in which the result the Alzheimer's
disease was actually the result of a low
concentration of acetylcholine in this
synaptic cleft between two neurons right
so acetylcholine is actually made from
acetate and calling buy a calling
acetyltransferases and degraded by an
enzyme that is called as I recall in
estrace alright so when acetylcholine is
released into the synaptic cleft finds
its way into receptors which are in the
postsynaptic neuron one of them the
muscarinic acetylcholine receptor is
actually a g-protein coupled receptor
and so it was then proposed that that
signaling cascade that resulted from
that interaction actually was affecting
the processing of a PP which is the
protein that actually are is the
precursor to the beta-amyloid peptide
which aggregates into the plaques so the
cholinergic hypothesis that was proposed
in 1975 blame
low amounts of as a recording in the
synaptic cleft for the production of the
beta-amyloid peptide so from this model
it was very clear where the solution was
well then develop a drug that could
actually restore normal levels of acid
colony that's a synaptic cleft and that
target was actually the colonists race
the acetylcholinesterase the enzyme that
degrades acetylcholine so the first and
all degeneration of actually drugs what
they do is they block the activity of
acetylcholinesterase restoring normal
levels of acetylcholine in the synaptic
cleft and clinically it was predicted
that if that was the case then
downstream the production of
beta-amyloid peptide was going to
decrease and the progression will be
disorder was going to slow down right so
these are the drugs that are current in
current use so the cholinergic
hypothesis was proposed in 1975 the
first drugs that came into the clinic
into clinical use where aricept and
rivastigmine this compound is completely
synthetic this is actually derived from
a natural product by so stick mean that
occurs in a African legume which is
actually very toxic so the other
compound actually or the other asset of
cholinesterase inhibitor approved in
2004 is galantamine that actually occurs
in a host of plants I just cited
daffodil because it's very timely right
now to talk about that so and is it is
used as it is found actually in in these
plants there is an alternative treatment
that blocks actually the receptor of
glutamate which it is thought to
contribute to the formation of the hell
protein three wheels in the in the
neurons and this is all that exists in
clinical use
and their efficacy it's actually
extremely poor right so given the
interest that we had in this in this and
I'm going to start to abbreviate because
I'm running out of time now so we
started to so we decided to look for as
a record necessaries inhibitors so the
question was what type of plants are we
going to look for to to screen for
hysterically registration division so
the plans that we decided to target
we're plans that have been claimed to
possess neurotropic activity and neuro
tropics or defined you know as agents
that can be or act at memory enhancers
nor enhancers cognitive enhancers etc
and the aetna bud knees are rich in
those types of descriptions so so the
question I was how we going to measure
this well we had actually a fluorometric
essay to do it but it just was too it
was not very practical to to use it it
is very good at quantitating activity
and gathering kinetics but not very
quick for targeting a particular
component in in a plan so we opted to
use an alternative which is a by
autographic assay that can be developed
in a thin layer chromatography it
entails the resolving the components of
a mature until on TLC applying the
enzyme and then a reagent that generates
a background and contrasts with a
discoloration which is actually an
indicator of acetylcholinesterase in
division and here's the proof of concept
this is the essay and this whitish
discoloration here is actually aricept
the drug that is used clinically so now
we had an assay and we decided then on
web plans we were going to target so one
of the first plants that we actually
targeted was maca lepidium ani and
andean brassicae see
that traditionally is used for the
treatment of male infertility but that
it lists as another benefit actually
improvement in memory and brain function
so this is the assay as it looks so we
diagnose that these areas of this
coloration in particular we're due to
alkaloids in in Makkah as we got a
positive with dragon door free agent
which is highly specific for alkaloids
and we're going on to isolate those
components and I'm not going to discuss
in depth but these are the types of
alkaloids that were found in Makka
they're very unique it made us all type
of Al alkaloids surprisingly maca this
brass Acacius plant contains also alkyl
amides and all acetylcholinesterase
inhibitors so it could be the foundation
for the claim you know that Makka prolly
benefits memory and n function so
another plan that we another nootropic
plan that we targeted also islamabad
beliefs officinalis in the lamiae see
that there is a claim that alleviates a
mile Alzheimer's so he is the second
cholinesterase inhibition assay this or
the spots that we targeted there are
others but we felt that this was the
major component you say fan all the
compound as it gives positive with very
chloride and ultimately we decided that
very likely this compound was rosmarinic
acid we run hplc analysis compared with
an authentic sample overalls man the
Kaiser and sure enough it's there in the
indie in the extracts of the plant and
confirm by mass spectrometry so so this
would be in summer these are the
acetylcholinesterase inhibitors that are
we have isolated one alkyl amide and two
alkaloids from lapeer ma ni and one
phenylpropanoid in melissa officinalis
rosmarinic acid ok so lastly I'm just
going to briefly discuss menopause in
our interest in menopause and actually
is an extension of the Alzheimer's
disease interest that we have
so participants in this project or
research is Marianne Kamal Jeanette and
in Heather so we had interest in
actually quite oestrogens for a number
of reasons one of them was very
pragmatic and that is well this
particular group of plants have been
utilized for a purported estrogenic
activity these two black cohosh and red
clover have been utilized in alternative
treatment of menopause Sinta mythology
these are the two actually have been
used traditionally as collectibles to
increase breast milk production in
lactating women so we felt that these
two types of effects were caused by the
presence of estrogen mimics so but at
the same time we felt that the there was
no really good hold on the estrogenic
chemistry chemistry had been described
but not never conclusively demonstrated
that those reports compounds where the
phytoestrogens so in a revisionist above
approach we decided okay let's look
again at this plan so we have now a an
interest we have plans to look at or we
needed now was to to find out how can we
do this so so menopause is a age-related
biological phenomenon results in the
reproductive acaba and the loss of the
reproductive capacity of a woman and
it's caused by gradual decrease in
estrogen production in the ovaries so as
we reviewed the literature and we're
getting ready to investigate are
estrogen mimic activity we realize that
estrogen was actually integral to a
number of symptoms associated with
menopause so there are the classical
ones and there or the result from that
the decrease in in estrogen and decrease
in progesterone
but one thing actually caught our
interest cited amongst the umbrella
designation of psychological symptoms
was actually poor memory and that cut
our interest so how is this I mean what
is the relationship between loss of
memory or decline in memory and estrogen
well there are a number of studies that
actually have conclusively demonstrated
that there is an association between our
correlation between the progression of
menopause and the decline and memory and
cognitive function so this is one of the
more recent ones published in 2013
conducted at the University of Rochester
which a group of middle aged women in
different stages of menopause well
actually tested physiologically and
psychologically for verbal learning
capacity verbal memory fly motor skills
and attention working memory and as you
can see these bars represent the women
the groups of women in the different
stages and as you can see especially in
verbal memory there is a decline
associated with a progression of of
menopause and it's true for all of the
other functions that actually were
measured so here we have actually a very
concrete evidence that there too or
associated so now mechanistically why is
that why is that well looking at the
literature we now been able to summarize
some of the brain functions that
estrogen actually performs in the brain
so estrogen actually is a regulator of
the enzyme that bow synthesizes
acetylcholine right so the enzyme is
Colleen acetyl transferase so as so this
enzyme is on their positive regulation
of estrogen so the other function of
estrogen is envisioned as regulating the
processing of a PP and via the
modulation of the enzyme
that cleave a pee-pee and in the
presence of estrogen the amyloidogenic
pathway that leads to the formation of
the amyloid plaques is actually down
regulated and the third property is
actually if you notice a ring of
estrogen is aromatic with a hydroxyl
group this compound is antioxidant so it
performs also a neuroprotective function
in the brain now if you remove estrogen
from the brain all this happens okay the
protection as an antioxidant is lost the
upregulation of chat is lost less
acetylcholine has produced and it
actually increases the risk in a woman
to develop Alzheimer's disease and we
know very clearly the statistics women
or at twice the risk of developing a
severe disease than men right so these
actually are led us to formulate a
different approach to the study of
estrogens and because of the role of
estrogen in a menopause and what we're
looking for now is what I call
combinatorial pharmacology in plants
that is chemistry in plants that can act
as an antioxidant that can act as a
promoter of acid calling formation and
that can act as an estrogen mimic to
reduce the risk of developing
Alzheimer's disease right so we have
counter now actually those plants this
is how we assay for estrogenic activity
we engineered and not again another
yeast cell with this particular plasmid
that contains the human estrogen
receptor and ayvalik beta galactosidase
reporter gene so the plasmid is
introduced in the cell and we have now
an engineer yeast cell that upon the
stimulus of estrogen or estrogen mimic
actually triggers the expression of beta
galactosidase that process o MPG 2mp
that we can measure then
spectrophotometrically here's the proof
for concept
such construct treated with estrogen
results in a positive response alright
so the first plant that we actually
approached for study is fenugreek a pub
AZ used since activity for a number of
reasons but is used actually as a
galactic prominently to increase a
lactation in in women so I'm not going
to I'm just going to go to the to the
results and the chemistry that we have
actually isolated and identified
conclusively so one estrogenic component
of fenugreek exactly Dallas genin we
isolated characterize it and evaluate it
is this titanic activity is in the
chloroform methanol extract and in da
case a tunnel extract of a fellow Greek
actually we isolated three isoflavones
which are actually the same three
isoflavones plus present in soy and we
know that this isoflavones I mean have a
estrogenic mimicking capacity so they're
present also in fenugreek and the
presence of this chemistry is actually
responsible for the estrogenic activity
we now have defined a larger group of
plants to study the junior on the grad
students that were working in this
project have a tablished estrogenic
activity antioxidant activity and
acetylcholinesterase innovation activity
and they're the process of isolating the
active principles in this plan all of
them in the earth lamiaceae primarily
salvias which or or have been shown to
be estrogenic now I'm going to stop
there I just want to acknowledge see I
knew that I had too many slides so this
is this is this is a summary of
chemistry that is Astro genic and
acetylcholinesterase inhibitory so the
so Flavin's and die alten in leicester
team in mixing in trend greek and
another plant that we have studied is a
jawan to experiment Amy in the APA see
that contains estrogen mimics our
phenolic acids all of them which also
show a silicone estrace activity I would
like you to acknowledge the rest of the
undergrad students that are working my
life throughout the years I did get a
chance to talk about their projects in
chemical ecology malaria diabetes and
cancer all of them already in graduate
school thank you for your attention this
has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu